[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
auditions publiques une heure en invité
tous les lundis soir à 19h30 sur SCP et
Public Sénat soyez donc le bienvenu ce
soir c'est un ministre qui va être au
four et au moulin dans les semaines qui
viennent Franck Riester vous êtes
ministre délégué chargé des relations
chargées du Parlement soyez le bienvenu
bonsoir
la réforme des retraites a été soumise
au Conseil des ministres ce matin elle
arrive donc à la au Parlement et à
l'Assemblée nationale plus précisément
dans une semaine lundi est-ce que ce
sera chaudron une ZAD comme le
souhaiterait par exemple la verte marine
Tondelier quel amendements êtes-vous
prêts à approuver donnerez-vous du grain
à moudre aux oppositions beaucoup
dénoncent par ailleurs la brutalité de
la réforme sur le fond y ajouterez vous
la raideur du 49.3 elles sont
envisageables vous êtes très attendus
sur toutes ces questions par Brigitte
Béjean par Brigitte boucher pardon et
Tom traduire dans quelques arrive très
rare qui se concentrera sur les
questions politiques Vincent roux lui
aura quelques questions d'actualité avec
vous et on vous en remercie vous avez
accepté le principe du débat avec la
sénatrice socialiste Monique Rubin et
mon petit doigt me dit qu'elle voudra
vous parler des retraites elle aura des
arguments je disais le texte est arrivé
en conseil des ministres un moment clé
du quinquennat cette réforme Franck
Riester
oui c'est une étape importante puisque
c'est une réforme importante
et on voit bien qu'il suicide beaucoup
de commentaires de critiques
d'opposition et donc c'est évidemment à
chaque fois qu'on réforme les retraites
un moment fort d'un quinquennat surtout
que le Président de la République la non
c'est dans sa campagne et les députés de
la majorité l'ont annoncé dans leur
campagne que c'était une réforme que
nous voulons fier que nous voulions
faire assez vite dans le quinquennat et
c'est aussi important parce que c'est au
cœur de l'adaptation de notre dispositif
de protection pour le sécuriser je
rappelle quand même que le système de
retraite répartition c'est un des
piliers de notre protection sociale
de solidarité intergénération je vous ai
dit le programme on va en parler
largement est-ce que politiquement c'est
un moment clé du quinquennat
écoutez on a depuis le début du
quinquennat mené un certain nombre de
réformes celle-là est une réforme
importante mais c'est pas non plus
l'alpha et l'oméga de notre quinquennat
et du quinquennat du premier de la
République quand même
on est enfin moi j'ai la conviction que
c'est une réforme difficile une réforme
qui faut expliquer sinon réforme sur
lequel on aura l'occasion de discuter
beaucoup au Parlement mais c'est une
réforme que les Français
avaient bien anticipé puisque le premier
République encore une fois et tous les
députés de la majorité on fait campagne
là-dessus donc on a pris personne par
surprise et donc
on a la détermination de la monnaie à
terme pour sauver le système de
répartition et ensuite il y a beaucoup
d'autres régions
de la République a parlé
de défense avec la loi de programmation
militaire il y a la question de la
profession la justice
c'est une étape mais parmi d'autres et
nous pensons que on a on ne veut pas si
vous voulez c'est pas encore une fois
l'alpha et l'oméga de toute façon parmi
d'autres c'est la réforme non
justement c'est difficile vous la mettez
bien sûr
le débat qu'il y a les manifestations et
ça l'a toujours été je me rappelle moi
j'étais déjà débuté député entre 2007 et
2012 il y a eu la réforme menée par Eric
World notamment c'est un moment
difficile la réforme Touraine menée sous
Hollande qui était une réforme du Sud à
chaque fois on sait bien parce que
leur travail un texte difficile est-ce
que on ne donne que 20 jours à
l'Assemblée nationale pour en débattre
au départ est-ce que c'est sérieux de
nous donner que 20 jours
en commission à l'hémicycle pour un
texte aussi important en fait c'est une
réforme qui permet d'assurer l'équilibre
financier de notre système par
répartition et donc la grande majorité
des dispositions pour cette réforme sont
des dispositions d'ordre financières qui
sont du ressort d'un projet de loi de
finance de la sécurité sociale qui ont
un impact sur le financement de la
sécurité sociale et je dirais même c'est
pour ça que c'est un rectificatif y
compris sur le budget de la Sécurité
sociale de cette année puisque la
réforme des premiers septembre
la Constitution notre loi fondamentale
encadre la discussion au Parlement de
ces lois de finances de la sécurité
sociale il y a 50 jours de débats et
finalement quand on regarde de près
c'est beaucoup et 20 jours en première
lecture à l'Assemblée nationale
concrètement il va y avoir
outre la discussion générale et
l'audition du ministre qui a eu lieu
tout à l'heure en commission trois jours
complets de discussion des amendements
sur les 10 articles du projet de loi
trois jours complets en commission et
dans l'hémicycle deux semaines complètes
c'est bien assez oui nous pensons que
d'abord encore une fois c'est pas nous
qui choisissons le nombre de jours pour
sur le pour le pendant lesquels on
discute de ce type de réforme c'est la
Constitution qu'il décide et qui décide
de dire c'est 20 jours en première
lecture à l'Assemblée et on a fait en
sorte
de débats dans l'hémicycle à l'Assemblée
nationale sur un sujet qui est connu
depuis toujours depuis très longtemps en
tout cas parler députés sur 10 articles
nous pensons qu'il y a largement le
temps de débattre de proposer des
amendements de voter les différents
articles et le texte évidemment après ça
dépend des oppositions et ce qui en
parle obstruction pas obstruction si
obstruction évidemment c'est ça va
compliquer le temps de débat s'il y a
pas obstruction on pense que largement
avec deux semaines plein de débats
programmés à l'Assemblée nationale pour
débattre de ce texte et ensuite il y
aura 15 jours au Sénat en première
lecture et 5 on avance en tout cas vous
avez des réformes difficiles il y a
largement le temps en 20 jours de
l'examiner retiens cela en première
lecture bien sûr en face de vous
Brigitte boucher bonsoir Brigitte et Tom
traduisez
alors est-ce que vous êtes sûr
d'utiliser l'article 47 1 de la
Constitution qui dit que sans vote au
terme de ces 20 jours justement vous
saisissez le Sénat le texte du
Gouvernement par directement au Sénat
pour être étudié nous nous souhaitons
aller au bout de la discussion de tous
les articles et donc d'aller au vote en
première lecture à l'Assemblée nationale
avant le délai des 20 jours et ce que je
disais à l'instant c'est que ça va
dépendre des oppositions la Constitution
effectivement prévoit que au bout de 20
jours le texte est transmis au Sénat si
on n'a pas eu le temps d'aller jusqu'au
bout de la discussion et je rappelle que
en théorie c'est prévu pour un texte
total de projet de loi de finance de
sécurité sociale sur tous les sujets
c'est à dire sur les programmes de santé
sur le d'autonomie sur les politiques de
financement de la sécurité sociale donc
avec beaucoup de sujets abordés là on se
concentre sur 10 articles sur la réforme
du financement de notre système de
retraite de répartition pour m'assurer
sa pérennité donc on voit bien que ces
dispositions qui sont très larges
finalement pour un téléss dans son
ensemble vont être utilisés pour cette
réforme financière de notre régime de
retraite
d'utiliser le 47- menacé
les journalistes ne l'ont pas sorti de
leur chapeau un moment le gouvernement a
bien commencé à parler du canon
franchement jamais nous n'avons c'est la
Constitution nous invente rien au départ
les oppositions chez les oppositions qui
nous ont taxées de ça les opposants nous
dire ah bah ils utilisent un PLFSS parce
que ils veulent utiliser le 49-3 je
dirais d'une façon facile sans avoir à
utiliser un joker puisque vous savez que
le 49-3 lorsqu'il s'agit d'un texte
financier on peut l'utiliser autant
qu'on veut alors que quand c'est un
texte classique on l'utilise qu'une
seule fois par session donc c'est parce
que vous l'utilisez le 49-3 sans
utiliser votre Joker et puis après ils
sont aperçus que on était toujours dans
cette logique depuis le départ de ce
mandat à la demande du prénom République
et la première ministre de trouver des
majorités que nous étions 3 trouver une
majorité est clair et que nous allions
pas avoir besoin de 49,3
toujours essayer de nous attaquer sur la
forme ils ont dit ils vont utiliser 47
ans ce fameux amendement de la fin
arctique de la Constitution qui
permettent transmettre le texte au Sénat
au bout de 20 jours de discussion mais
nous nous avons toujours en tête et
c'est la première ministre qui le répète
systématiquement la volonté d'aller
jusqu'au bout du débat alors vous dites
qu'il y a un vote ça veut dire que vous
pourrez utiliser le 49-3 pour le
collotex ou pas une majorité de députés
qui votent cette réforme qui est
importante qui est au cœur de la
sauvegarde de notre système de retraite
par répartition pilier de notre
protection sociale
de notre cohésion sociale et de notre
contrat social si vous n'arrivez pas au
bout du débats et donc nous voulons
avoir une majorité que ce texte soit
voté que tous les articles soient votés
que le texte soit
trop court dans ces dans ces deux
semaines et à ce moment-là la
Constitution s'appliquera oui mais vous
direz à cause des oppositions
j'accuserai les oppositions de les avoir
cette extrémité avec le 47 d'abord on
arrive
concentré serein et conscient de la
difficulté de faire voter une réforme
des retraites dans notre pays on en est
conscient et donc on va y aller en étant
ouvert aux discussions ouvert aux
remarques des députés avec la volonté de
donner des réponses de de donner des
avis d'affirmer nos positions de
soutenir la stratégie politique et la
nôtre vous pourriez passer par
ordonnance si une fine vous n'avez pas
de
de vote en fait il y a effectivement la
Constitution prévoit que à l'issue des
50 jours alors là on est à la fin on
atterrissage final du texte après la
navette il y a après les échanges entre
l'Assemblée Sénat si au bout de 50 jours
c'est pas fini à ce moment-là il peut y
avoir un débat enfin une mise en œuvre
de la réforme ordonnance bon je pense
vraiment qu'on n'est pas du tout dans
scénario là encore une fois parce que
nous voulons
avoir un vote avant la fin des 50 jours
avec une majorité plus large c'est ce
qui nous mobilisent aujourd'hui et je
nous pensons que nous sommes en mesure
de l'atteindre avec notamment des
députés et des sénateurs et l'air et les
sénateurs du centre pour ce qui concerne
en espérant que vous aurez tous les
vôtres dans votre majorité on entend
plutôt un certain nombre de voix
discordantes qui se font attendre depuis
plusieurs jours un barbara Pompili
Patrick Vignal Yannick favnack etc ils
sont Renaissance modem horizons et puis
il refuse de voter la réforme des
retraites en l'état ça y est vous avez
vos frondeurs non ben écoutez on est au
début d'un débat parlementaire un débat
parlementaire où les députés pour ce qui
concerne l'Assemblée nationale et
sénateurs concernent le Sénat vont
émettre des avis vont faire des
propositions et y compris pour la
majorité ma conviction très forte pour
l'avoir discuté avec ces députés pour
avoir vu leur électorale parce que c'est
députés
et je sais que leur état d'esprit et je
sais dans quel est dans quel état
d'esprit ils sont y compris pour ce
texte de loi j'ai vu aussi leur campagne
il leur document de campagne on voit
bien que les députés de la majorité se
sont présentés devant les Français en
faisant en sorte de défendre la réforme
prévue par le Président de la République
ils disent qu'il faut aller plus loin
sur la salle dont deux points on va
regarder avec eux ce sur quoi on peut
améliorer le texte je rappelle quand
même que ce texte a été largement
modifié par rapport à ce qu'elle avait
même présenté le président de la
République dans sa campagne parce qu'il
avait dit âge légal de par 65 ans en
état 64 ans donc on a écouté on a écouté
notamment des députés de la majorité et
des députés et des députés et des
sénateurs et de les républicains c'est
vrai sur le la retraite minimum aussi
qui va être élargie non seulement aucune
voix ne manquera dans la majorité mais
aussi aux retraités déjà en retraite
déjà en retraite et donc nous avons déjà
beaucoup mobilisé le texte et nous vous
allons continuer travailler avec les
activités
les députés de la majorité vont voter
tous
on va arriver sur le fond de la réforme
il y a des points importants un mot
quand même sur ces troupes qui proposent
une augmentation de la durée de travail
à 35,5 heures pour générer plus de
cotisations ça c'est du côté du MoDem
qu'est-ce que vous dites à cela
dit que là pour le coup clairement on va
pas ouvrir un autre débat autour de la
durée du travail sur le temps de travail
là on se concentre sur la retraite je
crois qu'on a discuté j'en ai discuté
avec Jean-Paul Mattei la première
ministre aussi et ça va la portée
de position je sais pas mais en tout cas
ils ont bien compris que c'est pas
quelque chose sur lequel on pouvait
travailler avec eux dans un sens positif
alors il y a un autre point de
crispation ce sont les 44 ans ces
Français qui seraient obligés de
travailler jusqu'à 44 ans alors qu'ils
ont des carrières longues qu'ils ont
commencé à travailler à 16 17 ou 18 ans
est-ce que ça vous pourriez revenir
dessus pour qu'ils travaillent 43 ans
comme toutes les autres concernés par la
réforme alors d'abord on maintient un
dispositif de carrière longue je dirais
encore plus
adapté aux spécificités de nos
compatriotes dans leur travail avec un
notamment
on crée une
il y a une une
assasse de deux ans entre 16 et 18 ans
qui n'existaient pas donc il y a les
moins de 16 ans il y a les 16 à 18 il y
a 18 à 20 ans et à chaque juste elle
pendant 44 et ça c'est important parce
que ils auront à
bénéficier de dispositif du carrière
longue pour ceux qui ont commencé à
avancer ans s'ils ont validé un salon de
trimestres ils partiront à 58 ans de 16
à 18 ans 60 ans et de 18 à 20 ans 62 ans
donc avant le déplage légal de 64 ans et
il travaille un an plus de cotisations
un travail à 4 du cotisation un an de
plus que le nombre de d'années de
cotisations minimum de 43 ans mais le
système et on l'assume de retraite a
toujours fonctionné avec deux critères
un critère d'âge légal de départ et un
critère
il y avait jusqu'à deux ans ou trois ans
de plus de cotisations travaillées de
Daniel cotisation travailler par rapport
pour pouvoir partir en retraite là il y
a qu'une année 43 et 44 et jusqu'à
présent il y avait 5 ans d'écart entre
l'âge de départ et l'âge de départ sans
décote c'est-à-dire en considérant qu'on
a tous les trimestres
validés
et on bouge pas cet ancre là comme on
dit souvent sauf que la durée de
cotisation à 43 ans qui était dans le
texte annoncé pour tout le monde non non
c'était pas pour tout le monde ça jamais
été pour tout le monde
Touraine ça fait quand même partie des
grandes lignes de la réforme annoncée
vous le faites bien de le préciser que
c'était la réforme Touraine qui avait
fixé comme durée minimum de cotisations
43 ans mais je le répète c'est durer
minimum et il faut aussi valider l'âge
légal de départ alors ça c'est en tout
cas et donc mais c'est important parce
que il s'agit pas d'un âge s'il s'agit
pas d'un dispositif qui aurait pu se
faire qui est dire on regarde uniquement
la durée les cotisations et pas l'âge
légal mais c'est un système qui est non
seulement ça serait un peu compliqué de
l'expliquer en détail ici mais qu'un
sujet un système non seulement injuste
et aussi qui n'est qui ne permet pas
d'équilibrer le système donc là on a un
système avec deux critères la durée de
cotisation minimum et là je gagne et
jamais encore une fois j'insiste parce
que cette réforme allait plus juste
notamment par ce point là il y a jamais
aussi peu d'écart entre ceux qui sont à
la durée de cotisation minimum et ceux
qui sont obligés de faire plus pour
avoir l'âge légal un an d'écart et il y
a un an d'écart et il y a 3 ans d'écart
entre l'âge légal et l'âge de départ
sans décote avant il y avait 5 ans et
avant il y avait trois ans
publics pour voter cette cette réforme
prévale sur l'âge légal en tout cas un
certain nombre de députés LR je le
préfère se présente
disent qu'il faut que la durée de
cotisation passe avant vous avez besoin
de ces voies LR pour voter la réforme
est-ce que vous pensez du coup pouvoir
la faire passer
puisque comme vous l'avez dit c'est
certain c'est ce sont certains députés
écoutez on a besoin de maximum de voix
bien évidemment vous n'avez pas besoin
mais c'est ça que vous nous dites on a
besoin du maximum de députés qui ont
conscience que la responsabilité qui est
la nôtre face aux Français c'est de
prendre les décisions par vous
difficiles pour pérenniser un système de
retraite qui est encore une fois
absolument clé pour les plus modestes et
qui est au cœur de la solidarité
intergénérationnelle
que le prix dans la République dans sa
campagne et nous aujourd'hui on fait pas
ça juste pour s'embêter ou juste pour se
faire plaisir sur l'été sadique on fait
ça voyez les difficultés et on voit bien
que c'est pas populaire à votre votre
collègue du gouverne et on le fait parce
que c'est l'intérêt général du pays
alors il dit il faut le rappeler on le
fait pas encore une fois par idéologie
vous la volonté de sauvegarder un
système qui est le pilier de un des
piliers de notre côté alors cette
réforme on a que des gagnants mais il y
a l'étude d'impact qui dit clair il y a
des perdants ce sont les mots qu'il a eu
bon c'est pas grave mais c'est important
dans l'étude d'impact il est montré que
les femmes vont partir en moyenne 7 mois
plus tard tandis que les hommes
partiront eux 5 mois plus tard est-ce
que c'est une réforme qui va accroître
les inégalités hommes femmes non mais en
fait ce qui se passe c'est que les
femmes pour pouvoir
atteindre leur durée de cotisation
utilise et c'est bien légitime et on le
conforte dans cette réforme utilise
notamment des trimestres valider par
enfant et donc ça leur permet d'accéder
plus facilement au trimestre minimum
pour pouvoir valider et une retraite
sans décote voilà évidemment si vous
reportez l'âge légal elles sont
évidemment un peu pénalisés par ce
report de l'âge légal on en dit ce qu'on
vient absolument pas en revanche
elles sont un peu un peu plus impactés
du fait
sur ce point là particulier elles sont
un peu plus impactées que les hommes
puisque elles bénéficient de trimestres
par enfant que les hommes n'ont pas pour
ces enfants et elles ont donc c'est très
technique mais avec le report de l'âge
le les trimestres par enfant ne jouent
pas sur le report de l'âge il joue sur
la durée de cotisations pour autant on
va expliquer une femme par exemple pour
répartir à 62 ans admettons avec les
trimestres qu'elle aura gagné avec ses
enfants mais comme il y a un âge légal à
64 ans
bon et donc
on a en revanche un dispositif qui est à
leur avantage qui est le dispositif de
la prise en compte notamment pour les
carrières longues des congés parentaux
ce qui n'était pas le cas précédemment
et donc ça c'est un avantage pour les
femmes d'autre part le récompensé la
mesure de l'âge légal c'est ce que
montre l'étude d'impact ça veut dire ça
vient quelque chose de positif
avec ça il y a aussi la
[Musique]
prendre en compte les difficultés de nos
compatiales
de justice on compte les congés
parentaux qui n'étaient pas parce que
vous avez dit minimum ça va bénéficier
notamment aux femmes la question est
précise parce que c'est un des points
clés aussi Olivier du soft a ouvert la
voie des mesures plus coercitives est-ce
que vous allez sanctionner directement
les entreprises qui licencie les seniors
non c'est pas prévu de cette façon là on
va continuer de travailler sur ce
système aujourd'hui seront pénalisés les
entreprises qui ne publient pas leur
index seniors pour savoir où ils en sont
dans l'emploi des seniors on a besoin de
travailler avec les les représentants
des entreprises avec les entreprises sur
des entreprises aussi qui ont des
dispositifs de départ anticipé je dirais
d'une façon institutionnalisée et on va
regarder avec les parlementaires avec
les partenaires sociaux comment on peut
aller plus loin dans la contrainte parce
que on est convaincu que l'emploi des
seigneurs c'est quoi quand il dit ça
Olivier du soft c'est quoi c'est l'index
des seniors qui aujourd'hui la
pénalisation qui est dans le texte c'est
de dire dans notre projet de loi c'est
de dire sont sanctionnés financièrement
qui ne publie pas on verra de quelle
manière il faut aller plus loin pour que
ça soit comme sanction financière plus
forte ou ça peut être ça on va écouter
ce que nous disent les parlementaires on
est à l'écoute mais c'est certain qu'il
faut que les entreprises jouent
mécaniquement du fait de la réforme mais
vous avez fait du report de l'âge légal
il y aura plus mécaniquement
la question d'origine vous dites pas de
fonction financière pour les entreprises
qui les censé plus que d'autres les
seniors
et on s'arrête là-dessus pour l'instant
c'est pas prévu et
ça paraît compliqué à mettre mais en
tout état de cause on veut avoir des
outils qui permettent de mettre
davantage la pression aux entreprises
mais sur l'emploi des seniors il y a ce
dispositif là mais il y a aussi le cumul
emploi retraite qui est très important
et qui est absolument améliorée c'est
important sur l'emploi cumule le cumule
qui nous écoutent que quand un retraité
cumule avec un emploi aujourd'hui c'est
cotisations qu'il paye ne lui permettent
pas d'améliorer sa pension de retraite
et ben demain ça sera le cas après merci
c'est très important et on va travailler
sur la sur la retraite progressive aussi
qui existe d'ores et déjà mais qui va
être facilité et qui va être élargi non
seulement aux salariés du privé mais
aussi aux agents publics merci beaucoup
Brigitte merci Tom rejoint tout de suite
Vincent roux en direct du fier au live
Vincent bonsoir vous avez une question
précise alors qui n'a rien à voir mais
qui est très pratique pour Franck
Riester
qui a été élu en Seine-et-Marne et
justement ça concerne l'Île-de-France et
là once bonsoir Franck reaster bonsoir
Elisabeth la hausse annonçait du passe
Navigo qui est actuellement passé donc
déjà de 75 euros à 84 euros à plus de 94
euros et
on parle d'une nouvelle hausse et ça
donne des idées à David Belliard adjoint
maire de Paris il propose pour financer
les toutes les infrastructures et éviter
une hausse exponentielle de spas Navigo
une taxe sur les colis Amazon 50
centimes par colis et sur les SUV est-ce
de votre point de vue Franck Riester le
point de vue d'élus une bonne
d'abord c'est la région de définir le
prix du Pass Navigo je rappelle que
l'État a été en soutien des régions et
notamment de la région Île-de-France en
fin d'année 2022 ce qui a remis 200
millions d'euros en soutien à la région
pour le financement des transports c'est
à la région de trouver les voies et
moyens de financement de ce Pass Navigo
moi ce qui est certain c'est que tout ce
qui est taxe prélèvement l'alpha et
l'oméga de la politique de la gauche
d'une manière générale c'est pas la
nôtre et donc nous nous sommes pas
favorables par principe aux
augmentations de taxes aux augmentations
d'impôts
de regarder en détail à la fois ses
coûts ces ressources éventuelles autres
et en tout état de cause d'aller
fiscaliser et d'augmenter les impôts
c'est pas notre
tasse de thé on peut le dire comme ça
merci beaucoup Vincent à tout à l'heure
bonne soirée
rédaction du Figaro c'est à vous alors
on a beaucoup parlé du Parlement et
c'est normal vous êtes ministre en
charge des relations avec le Parlement
imaginez un cas de figure
avec les procédures parlementaires que
vous avez détaillé avec mes concerts
mais que la rue elle rejèbe avec des
millions de personnes dans la rue
qu'est-ce que vous faites
écoutez on écoute ce que dit la rue ça
vous fait peur non ça nous fait pas peur
vous savez moi je suis parlementaire
depuis 2007 j'ai vu plusieurs réformes
plusieurs textes de loi venir à l'agenda
du Parlement suscité des oppositions
sucer des manifestations et j'ai vu
aussi que quand on avait au moment de
l'élection nous et députés sénateurs ou
gouvernement annoncé clairement les
choses c'était beaucoup plus facile de
faire passer les réformes je prends
l'exemple du l'ouverture du mariage au
couple de même sexe il y a des millions
de personnes dans la rue partout en
France rappelez-vous
bon et bien François Hollande avait dit
dans sa campagne il a fait voter le
texte au Parlement et qui s'est rentré
dans les mœurs et
je pense que la force de et la force de
la légitimité démocratique de cette
réforme outre l'intérêt pour le pays
l'intérêt général que finalement les
gens qui regardent de près le sujet
reconnaissent c'est que le Président de
la République et les députés parce qu'on
dit souvent ah bah oui mais le
développement de la République au
deuxième tour c'était face à Le Pen et
donc ça valide pas son projet oui enfin
les députés de la majorité qui ont mis
dans leur document de campagne la
réforme des retraites eux ont été élu
ils représentent une majorité une
majorités
sérieux tempérament c'est que
contrairement au mariage pour tous où là
vous aviez pas d'interlocuteurs il
n'avait pas d'interlocuteur encore
constitué là les syndicats feront unis
ils sont contre mais ils appellent
beaucoup de monde dans la rue pour la
réforme de l'ouverture du mariage pour
les coups de même si il y avait beaucoup
beaucoup de monde dans vous avez pas
encore davantage que ce qu'on a vu la
dernière chose parce qu'il y a eu ça
aussi qui sait invité dans le débat
politique
on fera on ferait rien oui c'est une
réforme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure c'est
une réforme difficile bien évidemment
que il faut il faut prendre du temps
pour convaincre il faut du temps pour
écouter il faut du temps pour améliorer
les textes mais il faut aussi respecter
les engagements qu'on a pris et être
avoir une politique courageuse parce que
c'est l'intérêt général qu'il le dit il
nécessite les précédents j'en ai un
précédentes de trouver c'est le contrat
premier embauche alors j'étais pas
adopté j'étais pas député
ça n'a jamais été appliqué oui
mais est-ce que est-ce que Jacques
Chirac l'avait dit dans sa campagne
je pense que on peut dans ce pays
réformer avec des manifestations avec
des oppositions d'autant plus facilement
et on peut tenir les nos convictions et
nos positions d'autant plus facilement
que au moment de l'élection n'a été
claire alors on a entendu madame la
Première ministre on a entendu Olivier
du soft je cherche je sais plus où est
Bruno Le Maire il ne parle plus là
[Musique]
des médias régulièrement
le président de la République à votre
avis doit-il à un moment de façon
solennelle
s'exprimer sur le dossier des retraites
il l'a fait mais de façon annexe en
parlant d'autres choses est-ce que il
doit
il l'a fait dans sa campagne il l'a fait
pendant la campagne législative il l'a
fait assez vœu il la refait là encore à
chaque fois qu'on l'interroge sur le
sujet pierre personne ne peut douter du
soutien du président de la République
pour cette réforme et de son engagement
malgré tout ce que vous avez dit n'a pas
convaincu
il y a une forte puisque vous trouvez
que la pédagogie a été suffisante
pédagogie alors la pédagogie j'aime pas
trop ce terme mais disons il faut
continuer d'expliquer la réforme il faut
continuer d'expliquer pourquoi on l'a
fait continuer d'expliquer pourquoi elle
est non seulement nécessaire et par
certains aspects tout à fait juste et
apporte des progrès très clair pour nos
compatriotes est-ce que c'est un test de
résistance pour la majorité qui est
composite qui est fait de plusieurs
groupes et on le voit avec des idées
comme ça qui sortent un moment en disant
c'est pas assez social il faut allonger
la durée du temps de travail
hebdomadaire
comme ça c'est toujours des tests
évidemment de donc c'est un test
on parlait tout à l'heure est-ce que
c'est un moment politique particulier ça
fait partie des étapes importantes dans
d'un quinquennat sans pour autant être
l'alpha et l'oméga de toutes les
réformes la mer des réformes comme c'est
pas le test unique et seul pour l'unité
de la majorité puisque on a vu que le
test parce que je constate était reporté
au mois de juin par Madame la première
minute d'abord elle m'a dit attendez
c'est le texte va venir au printemps
comme d'ailleurs d'autres textes la loi
de programmation militaire on est en
train de caler ça c'est
je découvre un peu plus précisément la
difficulté en tant que ministre en
charge des relations avec le Parlement
de caler un agenda entre l'Assemblée le
Sénat les suspensions le temps de
contrôle du Parlement le temps
d'initiative parlementaire c'est
complexe donc il y a pas du tout de
volonté de repousser le texte de
l'immigration plutôt que d'un autre ça
va venir au fur et à mesure des de
l'agenda en fonction de ce qui est
possible de placer ce qui est certain
c'est que moi ce que je constate depuis
l'élection
législative et le nouveau quinquennat
c'est que la majorité est solide et que
la majorité est unie qu'il y a des
sensibilités mais que ce n'est pas au
détriment de l'unité de la force de
cette majorité regardez les textes qui
ont été votés la totalité des textes or
les deux textes financiers PLF et PLFSS
ont été votés avec le soutien de la
totale et sans état d'âme de la majorité
et même avec d'autres députés d'autres
partis politiques certains LR d'autres
partis socialistes et je peux vous dire
dans ce que je ressens des discussions
avec les députés Renaissance avec les
députés horizons les députés modem c'est
qu'à la volonté d'être ensemble pour
porter cette réforme importante pour le
pays donc il sera là au rendez-vous du
vote vous êtes vous dites
un handicap quand même majeur qu'on
n'avait jamais imaginé c'est que le
Président de la République a été élu et
qu'il ne peut plus se représenter et que
et ben en fonction de ça son autorité si
vous voulez notamment sur sa majorité
peut être à moins de riz par le fait
qu'il n'est pas à se représenter et que
des successeurs on on imagine c'est très
bien qui sait et bien pour recréer un
peu la zizanie mais par exemple Philippe
Édouard Edouard Philippe je Monsieur le
Maire Monsieur Darmanin tout est
possible
toutes les hypothèses sont
possibles ce que je vis et ce que vivent
les Français est-ce que voit les
Français c'est qu'on n'est pas du tout
là-dedans que la bataille de 2027 entre
guillemets
là le moment venu mais on n'y est pas du
tout mais vraiment pas du tout il y a
pas une fois je vais vous le dire ou
j'ai eu le sentiment et je pense que
vous partagez ou les députés de la
majorité ou les sénateurs de la majorité
ont une action
d'idées par cette question de la
présidentielle de 2027 franchement et on
parle beaucoup de devoir Philippe
d'horizon regardez ce qui se passe
franchement ils ont voté tous les textes
ils apportent des propositions pardon
utile et je là sur la réforme des
retraites aussi avec la volonté d'être
en soutien très fort de la République
averti au début du quinquennat en disant
si jamais et bien j'arrive pas à trouver
une majorité pour mes textes à
l'Assemblée nationale pour un texte je
dissous
il a dit d'abord il a il a dit quelque
chose qui est tout à fait juste c'est
qu'à partir du moment où il y aura une
motion de censure de voter pas pareil
non c'est pas pareil une motion de
censure de voter il faudrait faire
trancher les Français et que à partir du
moment où le gouvernement serait
renversé par une majorité de députés à
ce moment-là les Français trancheraient
mais c'est pas si on a sur un texte pas
de majorité non ça c'est la vie du
Parlement il peut y avoir des fois des
majorités des fois pas de majorité c'est
pas pour autant que il y aurait
dissolution vous êtes d'accord pour dire
qu'il ne peut pas reculer sur cette
réforme mais parce que ça a été une
réforme très importante et c'est une
réforme qui était annoncée très
clairement pendant la campagne et la
présidentielle et des législatives
bloqué de façon de façon persistante
pour autant pour autant on est toujours
à l'écoute et pour autant on a tenu
compte des remarques des français via
leur représentants d'organisation
syndicale via leur représentants
politiques et ce texte il a été
énormément modifié par rapport au texte
initial voulu notamment la retraite à 65
ans qui était dans la campagne du
président et des députés
parce que c'est oui ou c'est non il joue
son quinquennat là-dessus on dirait
Elisabeth Martichoux tout à l'heure mais
je vous assure il y a une cohérence dans
cette émission
que moi je vous dis que c'est pas
l'alpha et l'oméga mais c'est une
réforme importante au cœur de ce que
nous voulons faire dans la stratégie de
la pleine emploi parce que c'est par le
travail par un travail en davantage tout
au long de la vie qu'on arrivera à
pérenniser notre système de retraite et
à pouvoir créer suffisamment de richesse
pour continuer d'investir dans les
services publics dont on a besoin en
santé dans l'éducation
protéger face aux menaces d'où les
investissements dans l'armée et la
défense nous protéger au quotidien d'où
les investissements dans la justice et
dans la sécurité merci frère
dans un instant nous accueillons dans la
signatrice social existe Monique Lubin
un mot des boulangers qui était dans la
rue c'est un sujet aussi qui n'est pas
de votre autorité mais qui vous
intéresse évidemment ils ont manifesté
eux parce que
il subissent des hausses notamment de
factures d'énergie très importante
beaucoup disent qu'il n'y arrive pas
qu'ils vont mettre la clé sous la porte
qu'est-ce qu'on peut imaginer de plus
aujourd'hui pour les aider un bouclier
tarifaire alors il bénéficie d'ores et
déjà d'un dispositif très important
pour les attendez pour les TPE qui ce
qui était souhaité par le Président de
la République de contraindre les
fournisseurs d'électricité à garantir
280 euros du mégawattheure pour les
boulangers TPE c'est à dire de moins de
10 salariés pour les autres ils sont des
PME ils ont bénéficié de l'amortisseur
électricité qui représente une ristourne
de 20% de leur facture en gros plus plus
ensuite un guichet qui permettra ce
guichet d'avoir des solution très
adaptée et donc maintenant
le maire Olivia Grégoire sont vraiment à
l'écoute en soutien de nos artisans
boulangers les boulangers c'est au cœur
mais je peux pas vous donner une réponse
pour l'instant parce que il y a une
réponse majeure qui a été donné pour la
très grande majorité des boulangers qui
ont moins de 10 salariés qui ont ces 280
euros garantis sur l'année en moyenne du
mégawattheure c'est très important et
c'est une réponse très forte et pour les
autres les plus grandes entreprises
elles bénéficie comme les autres PME de
dispositif spécifiques et on verra dans
les semaines et les mois qui vient s'il
faut aller plus ou pas pour l'instant ça
ne vient pas à l'ordre du jour bonsoir
Monique lumin merci beaucoup d'être là
pour débattre avec le ministre Franck
Riester chargé des relations avec le
Parlement merci à tous les deux d'avoir
accepté le débat quel sujet sinon les
retraites ce soir et vous avez comme
vous voulez commencer par revenir sur le
dispositif carrière longue peut-être oui
on fait moi je voudrais revenir monsieur
le ministre sur ce en termes de justice
et de réformes juste que vous employez
tout le temps cette réforme elle va
toucher au coeur si je puis dire les
générations de 1961 à 1966 qui vont
subir la double peine à la fois du
nombre de trimestres augmentés et du
recul de l'âge de la retraite et dans
ces générations on trouve beaucoup de
gens qui ont commencé à travailler entre
18 et 20 ans qui ont des carrières
complètes et vous l'avez d'ailleurs je
vous ai attentivement écouté vous l'avez
dit un certain nombre d'entre eux
devront cotiser 44 ans
cette réforme ça n'est pas une réforme
des retraites en fait parce que si vous
aviez voulu faire une réforme des
retraites vous auriez fait vous vous
auriez fait un projet de loi retraite
dans lequel on aurait absolument tout
brosser c'est une réforme budgétaire que
vous faites au travers d'une loi de
finance de la sécurité sociale
rectificative
et donc elle sera comment dire
rapidement expédié on ne pourra pas
débattre et une loi de finance alors
quelle est la question précise ça c'est
le tableau
budgétaire et donc cette réforme
budgétaire elle fera des économies sur
le dos de ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler il y a longtemps où est la
justice alors d'abord madame la
sénatrice
une réforme budgétaire c'est-à-dire la
dimension financière d'un système de
retraite n'est pas quelque chose
d'anodin ou c'est pas un gros mot non
parce que je peux permettre de retourner
une question c'est comment vous financez
le déficit très clair qui va ce qui vont
se financer les déficits successifs qui
vont
d'années en année se cumuler pour le
système d'ordre sur le système de
retraite et menacer l'avenir du système
de retraite le corps dit très clairement
qu'à partir de 2027 on sera autour de 12
milliards de déficits par an 12 et demi
à partir de 2030
15 milliards puis 20 milliards c'est des
des 25 années de déficit à venir comment
vous faites pour financer les retraites
si vous ne demandez pas ce qui est le
cœur du fonctionnement de notre système
de retraite par répartition si vous
demandez pas aux actifs de travailler un
peu plus longtemps pour financer les
retraites des retraités il y a au moment
où on a une démographie qui est plus
importante qui ne pose problème
puisqu'il y a de moins en moins d'actifs
pour financer les retraités il y avait
trois actifs pour un retraité dans les
années 70 deux actifs pour un retraité
dans les années 2000 et aujourd'hui on
est à un actif virgule 7 pour un
retraité et on ne sera plus qu'à 1,4
dans les années 2030 comment vous faites
pour financer dire ça d'abord le choc
démographique et le corps le dit très
bien il a déjà eu lieu on est sur la
génération de de l'après-guerre qui
caprice sa retraite et le choc
démographique il a été compensé par des
gains de productivité premièrement
deuxième le corps dit aussi très
clairement que dans les années à venir
le les gains de productivité pourront
continuer à comment dire pallier cette
cette baisse de la démographie ensuite
vous ne regardez vous ne regardez que la
longement de la durée du temps de
travail il y a beaucoup d'autres
solutions mais on a l'impression
qu'elles sont toutes absolument c'est
quoi vos solutions par exemple permettre
l'équilibre du système de retraite parce
que sinon ce sont des déficits et de la
dette par exemple pourquoi ne
reviennent-on pas sur toutes les
exonérations de cotisations sociales que
votre gouvernement a mis en place depuis
5 ans toutes les heures supplémentaires
des socialisés le SMIC 1,6 des
socialisés défiscalisés dès qu'on prend
une mesure pour aider une entreprise
c'est des socialiser ces défiscaliser
donc petit à petit on est en train de de
vider notre protection sociale de sa
substance et au bout d'un moment on va
dire aux gens désolé il y a plus
d'argent vous devez travailler un peu
plus
on est vraiment c'est intéressant merci
de votre réponse clairement là sur deux
choix radicalement différents autre
choix en gros c'est de dire on n'est pas
obligé de demander aux Français de
travailler plus longtemps on peut
simplement augmenter les cotisations ou
baisser les exonérations de cotisation
on peut faire plusieurs pour les
entreprises ou pour les salariés parce
que la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires c'est des c'est du
pouvoir d'achat pour les salariés nous
on conteste formellement c'est le coeur
effectivement de notre projet politique
on veut maintenir le pouvoir d'achat de
nos compatriotes c'est-à-dire on veut
maintenir le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités et maintenir le pouvoir
d'achat des salariés qui par exemple par
leur travail en faisant des heures
supplémentaires
bénéficie de revenus complémentaires qui
est son défiscalisés des socialisés
et deuxièmement oui on conteste aussi
l'idée de d'augmenter les cotisations
sur les entreprises parce que si vous
augmenter les cotisations sur les
entreprises vous augmentez le coût du
travail et vous créez l'emploi et vous
vous perdez en compétitivité j'étais le
ministre du Commerce extérieur de
l'attractivité juste avant d'être
ministre en charge des relations avec le
Parlement on est en compétition mondiale
avec des concurrents européens des
concurrents dans le monde entier si nos
entreprises ne peuvent pas se battre à
armes égales avec les entreprises du
monde entier on perd des parts de marché
et donc on crée de du chômage et donc
c'est aussi et donc c'est aux salariés
de payer mais finalement il paye pas
justement mais non madame sénatrice
justement on veut leur donner la
possibilité de gagner davantage et de ne
pas être ponctionné par des impôts des
taxes les salariés et notamment ceux qui
ont des salaires les plus modestes il
est toujours question pour augmenter
leur pouvoir d'achat c'est de notre côté
baisser leur protection sociale parce
que les cotisations sociales les
cotisations sociales c'est du salaire
différé et si lorsque vous demandez à
des gens qui travaillent depuis l'âge de
18 ans qui travaille depuis 42 43 ans de
travailler un an de plus si
vous vous abaissez leur niveau de
protection sociale parce que ce sont
aussi ceux qui passent le moins de temps
à la retraite
au retraités actuel d'ailleurs je
préfère le dire que les retraites
actuelles faramineux vous avez fait des
cadeaux fiscaux pharamineux notamment
aux entreprises vous avez refusé de
taxer alors qu'on vous l'a proposé
depuis des mois à l'Assemblée comme au
Sénat vous refusez de taxer des grands
groupes qui ont gagné beaucoup d'argent
pendant la crise du covid et ce sont
finalement toujours les mêmes salariés
et vous savez ces salariés
ils savent ils ont parfaitement compris
exceptionnelle ou une taxe pérenne de
ces entreprises
oh je suis sur une taxe pérenne pourquoi
exceptionnelle dès lors que ce sont des
entreprises qui gagnent énormément
d'argent moi je pense qu'il faut revoir
les choses aussi régulièrement quand
tout va bien et que des entreprises
engrange beaucoup d'argent on peut
mettre des taxes et quand la situation
est moins importante on peut abaisser je
ne suis pas voilà mais ce que je
n'admets pas c'est que ce soit toujours
les salariés toujours les mêmes qui
peuvent
le coeur de notre système de répartition
de répartition c'est les actifs qui
financent les retraites des retraités si
vous
cassez ça vous cassez un des piliers de
notre système de retraite et c'est une
des grandes sécurité pour les salariés
et qui vont ensuite être en retraite
d'ailleurs je le dis cette réforme ne
n'impacte pas
quelques façons que ce soit négativement
les retraités et même positivement
puisqu'ils ont une revalorisation de
leur la retraite minimum de 100 euros
pour arriver à quatre gros 85 % du SMIC
donc ils sont bénéficiaires de cette
réforme et ça garantit la pérennité du
système de retraite et deuxièmement et
carrière complète pour une carrière vous
avez raison de me le faire préciser
parce que c'est très juste en revanche
vraiment et je respecte votre position
mais nous avons une position très
différente nous pensons que la stratégie
économique qui est la nôtre depuis
maintenant 5 ans et demi qui est de
baisser la fiscalité baisser les impôts
et des Français et des entreprises à des
résultats très positifs on n'a jamais eu
aussi peu de chômage dans notre pays
depuis 15 ans pour le chômage en général
pour les pour les Français dans leur
ensemble et pour depuis 25 ans pour les
jeunes on a la croissance la plus forte
de la zone euro parce que on a eu cette
politique de compétitivité cette
politique de l'offre de soutenir les
entreprises de soutenir celles et qui
travaillent et de rémunérer mieux ceux
qui travaillent et on a effectivement en
baissant et on a une inflation
forte et notamment sur les produits
alimentaires mais on a une inflation qui
est la plus faible parmi les plus
faibles de la de la des pays occidentaux
c'est une réalité qui se creuse monsieur
le ministre non toujours on a le pays
qui prélève le plus vous voulez des
impôts supplémentaires qui prélèvent le
plus de tous les pays occidentaux et qui
redistribue le plus et donc on a un des
pays les moins inégalitaires après après
redistribution c'est une réalité nous
avons effectivement nous sommes
effectivement dans un pays qui a été
très bien et on en est fiertable de
construire un formidable système de
protection sociale et quand je vous
écoute pas vous monsieur Riester mais le
gouvernement l'ensemble du gouvernement
il faudrait presque s'en excuser et
parce que nous avons cette formidable
protection sociale il presque que nous
nous disions bon on peut faire des
efforts et en avoir un peu moins moi ça
n'est pas ma vision des choses et ça
n'est pas pour ça que je suis engagé en
politique alors un mot des femmes
peut-être parce qu'il reste quelques
minutes de vous lire aussi évoquer cela
je trouve je trouve la communication
votre communication terrible
je salue le combat de madame la
sénatrice pour les femmes et c'est un
combat que nous partageons
cette réforme elle apporte vous l'avez
dit des choses positives pour les femmes
notamment les congés parentaux qui
seront pris en compte notamment nous
avons souhaité ne pas toucher au 67 ans
âge de départ en retraite sans décote et
qui évidemment bénéficier aux femmes
aujourd'hui
oui oui non mais j'entends mais enfin la
logique étant dans cette réforme de
demander un effort de report des âges
des différents âges de deux ans on
aurait pu et ça a été évoqué c'était
une des hypothèses repoussée aussi cet
âge de départ sans décote comme dans
d'autres pays européens nous ne l'avons
pas fait parce que justement on
considère que c'est un élément qui
aurait été très pénalisant pour les
femmes et puis en demandant travailler
plus longtemps et je vais les dis tout à
l'heure je le reconnais on demande plus
d'un effort aussi aux femmes de
travailler plus longtemps
mécaniquement le fait de cotiser plus
longtemps améliorera la retraite et
c'est toujours notre état d'esprit c'est
de dire qu'en cotisant plus longtemps
travaillant plus longtemps on améliore
le niveau de retraite oui le pouvoir
d'achat des retraites et donc c'est
effectivement c'est le travail plus long
qui permettra de gagner davantage et
donc et le revenu et l'amélioration de
la retraite minimum va bénéficier
majoritairement aux femmes par rapport
aux hommes et ça je reconnais que c'est
parce que les femmes gagnent moins donc
et sont celles qui majoritairement ont
des carrières complètes au SMIC plus que
les hommes mais en tout cas ça
améliorera leur retraite et ça ne
changera rien pour celle qui auront
arrêté de travailler pour élever des
enfants pendant un certain temps qui ont
des carrières hachées et et vous venez
de le répéter que l'on soit salarié
femme salariés femmes les deux j'ai
envie de dire double peine la seule
façon d'améliorer son pouvoir c'est de
travailler plus toujours plus allez
expliquer cela aux aides-soignantes aux
hôtesses de caisses aux infirmières à
tous ces métiers des carrières longues
ou des dispositifs de pénibilité
à mépriser royalement bon vaste sujet
parce que c'est aussi la question du
marché du travail qui était en jeu dans
cette affaire donc il faudrait aborder
toutes ces questions peut-être avant
l'égalité salariale entre les femmes et
les hommes qui est une vraie injustice
exactement
nous avions un véritable projet de loi
sur les retraites nous pourrions aborder
tout cela alors on va pas
faites les passer des bactéries vous le
ferez d'ailleurs lors du débat au Sénat
la communication effectivement sur la
situation des femmes dans cette réforme
des retraites c'est un gros sujet pour
le gouvernement effectivement mais vous
l'avez dit la réforme est difficile
l'expliquer aussi est assez compliqué
c'est très technique et on ne réglerait
on le dit avec beaucoup d'humidité on ne
règle pas pas non plus toutes les
difficultés de tous les salariés de ce
pays on essaie d'en améliorer beaucoup à
travers cette réforme et on va faire ne
pas tout on ne règle pas tout bien
évidemment il y aura encore des beaux
combats pour régler le problème des
inégalités c'est pas ça fonctionne c'est
ça que vous la fonction première c'est
garantir la pérennité du système voilà
et d'améliorer avec un certain nombre de
dispositifs les injustices qui existent
mais on n'a pas la prétention de régler
tout c'est magnifique
merci beaucoup et on va retrouver
Vincent roux en direct du Fiero live
pour une question d'actualité Vincent
oui Franck Riester je voulais vous
partager une question qu'on a posé aux
internautes du Figaro à une question où
il y a eu 200 000 votes et 67% de noms
non les lecteurs du Figaro les
internautes de Figaro ne croient pas à
la stabilité du couple franco-allemand
quel intérêt de s'accrocher à un
partenaire qui nous a obligé à
abandonner une partie de notre nucléaire
quel intérêt de s'accrocher un
partenaire peut-on lire encore qui a des
projets militaires qui font fine la
plupart du temps des matériels français
écoutez d'abord le premier élément qu'on
doit toujours avoir en tête c'est que
travailler en étroite collaboration avec
les Allemands se battent pour le couple
franco-allemand c'est assurer la paix
sur le continent européen en tout cas
sur la France la France et l'Allemagne
je rappelle qu'on a eu deux guerres
mondiales avec les Allemands que pendant
des décennies on s'est battu avec les
Allemands et que depuis la Seconde
Guerre mondiale nous sommes en paix dans
l'Union européenne grâce à ce couple
franco-allemand et grâce à l'Union
européenne
il faut veiller il faut mais pas du tout
mais pas du tout il faut veiller à ça
mais non c'est pas ça écoutez
là aussi moi j'étais en charge du
commerce régulièrement des bateaux avec
les Allemands de la politique en matière
de commerce on a réussi à rendre la
politique commerciale moins naïve parce
qu'on a fini par convaincre les
Allemands de la nécessité de bouger le
prix dans la République a réussi à
convaincre les allemand d'aller dans le
l'avion le futur avion européen le SCAF
nous avons réussi aussi à travailler sur
le futur char avec les Allemands il faut
convaincre il faut se battre on est en
train de faire sur la politique
énergétique nous sommes en train de le
faire sur la politique industrielle
c'est difficile mais c'est nécessaire
c'est nécessaire pour la paix et c'est
nécessaire aussi pour peser ton concert
des nations face aux États-Unis face à
la Chine face à la Russie face à la
Turquie face aux angles
face à ces états continents la seule
solution pour conforter notre
souveraineté et relever les défis qui
sont face à nous c'est d'être plus fort
en européen et qui dit plus fort en
Europe dit d'abord renforcer le lien
avec les Allemands même si c'est
difficile même si parfois on aimerait
avoir des décisions différentes des
Allemands il faut continuer de se battre
et de se mobiliser et on a des résultats
ils prennent la République à des
résultats en la matière Vincent c'est le
dernier mot
pour se battre pour le couple
franco-allemand rapidement je vous dis
ils ont ils vont faire l'avion du futur
le Scaff avec nous et on faire le futur
blindé avec nous ils ont accepté de
modifier la politique commerciale ils
ont ils ont ils ont accepté la ils ont
accepté de modifier la politique
commerciale européenne on a réussi à
mettre par exemple contre la vie au
départ des avions des Allemands en place
un dispositif de réciprocité dans
l'ouverture des marchés publics demain
on pourra exiger par exemple au chinois
européen voudront d'ouvrir les nôtres
aux produits chinois les Allemands ne
voulaient pas au départ on a réussi à
les convaincre il y a plein d'exemples
comme ça merci Vincent la semaine
prochaine bien sûr tiens une petite
question qui peut intéresser Monique
Lubin avant de partir avant de nous
quitter rapidement est-ce qu'il faut
baisser le nombre de parlementaires à
l'Assemblée comme au Sénat quelle est la
vie du ministre chargé des Relations
avec le Parlement oui ou non
on aura besoin d'avoir une réforme des
institutions le le public va lancer très
prochainement
de m'exprimer sur cette question non
c'est pas nous ce qui compte c'est la
les moyens des parlementaires la façon
dont ils sont élus et leur pouvoir et je
pense que sur ces trois points là on
peut améliorer le dispositif merci en
tout cas d'avoir accepté le débat merci
Monique Lubin d'être venu merci de nous
avoir suivis on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau nouvel
audition publique sur LCP Public Sénat
très belle soirée à vous tous
[Musique]